okay so we're going to talk about
testing everyone's favorite topic hot
off some like weird emulator talks we're
going to talk about the basic stuff and
nothing about hoover's unfortunately
um
so to anyone that hasn't met me and i
appreciate i am somewhat conspicuous
um i'm david i'm a software consultant
um
i wrote a few kids books and i've
built some massive web scale systems
hopefully you've used something i've
made even if you don't realize it but
what i really do is i perpetually play
with any and all technology i can get my
hands on and i've spent close to the
past 20 years writing all sorts of tests
and trying to do tdd in just about every
language and stack that i've had the
pleasure of working in
so are we ready to see how deep this
iceberg really goes if you pay close
attention to some great controversial
stuff in here
now a good portion of my own journey
with software testing involved
mostly good fortune and meeting the
right people at the right time
um see i i was originally a self-taught
developer
and you know the truth is my confession
is for the first 10 years of my
programming life i didn't write a single
test
didn't never heard of it and everything
seemed just
fine
honestly everything seemed just fine and
my code kind of worked and i didn't know
what i didn't know and i was happy
and i made it through an entire 2000s
early 2000s computer science degree with
nothing but the most casual reference to
unit tests being made um
trust those degrees folks
there are entire modules on the software
testing life cycle
but not a single instance of here's a
unit test it was all very 1990s
and
i was fortunate because in my very first
job out of university
i was lucky enough to have a mentor that
introduced me to the then relatively
nascent concept of unit testing and i
didn't really get it straight away at
all um
but working with this this mentor put me
on this path of discovery that really
hasn't stopped since and so if you you
know if he ever sees this that thank you
andy longshore you you really uh
you helped me when i was barely more
mature than a precocious teenager
um so while this talk on the surface is
kind of about how to write tests that
survive
and a little bit about javascript i
suppose it's also a little bit about my
own personal experience
because narcissist i don't know um
and and how it changed the path of my
entire career so it's gonna be one of
those sessions where we start somewhere
obvious and end up somewhere you might
not expect
somewhere down the bottom
so we're going to start by covering some
of the very very very very basics and um
from time to time i get asked the
question why i'm so enthusiastic about
automated testing because it isn't
really the sexy end of software for most
people
um it's the boring stuff it's the
tedious
work
but for me testing is beautiful
by testing is the thing we have that is
fundamentally of software that wasn't
borrowed or mimicked from another
discipline
it's the thing we invented it's our
process it's the thing that proves our
software works
so whenever i'm faced with folks asking
me
do i need to test x y or zed
or which part of the uh the software
should we skip testing like what's the
bits we don't need to test my my answer
is the same every single time
skip testing the bits of your software
that you're happy failing in production
because it will right it's inevitable
and um you know i'm not going to promise
you that great code of tests will stop
your software failing ever
but if you get your tests right
triangulating and fixing the software
when it does do those things and does
fail will be easier than ever
so let's talk about again the very
foundational basics for a moment and i'm
probably preaching to the choir a little
bit here because you've probably all
heard of unit testing before
um
but first a definition so in computer
programming unit testing is a software
testing method by which individual units
of source code sets one or more computer
program modules together with associated
control data usage procedures and
operating procedures are tested to
determine whether they are fit for use
thanks wikipedia who writes all that
stuff really
um we're going to start by talking about
you know the humble garden variety unit
test and what it is and what it isn't
so unit tests test a piece of code where
unit means the unit of isolation
now that's the thing that's being tested
right so unit tests
use you know they test functions they
test
single functions single classes
they are written with the help of a
testing framework and your test code is
executed using a test runner the thing
that discovers and executes your tests
and unit tests contain one or more
assertions lines of code that verify the
output of your function class or program
like very very foundational knowledge
and
um as as with most things in the whole
the javascript ecosystem it doesn't take
long to talk about a concept before
people start arguing what we're going to
use what we're going to install for npm
all that kind of stuff
the framework wars were bloody and there
were only casualties on the way
so all the examples here are just going
to be written in jest because it's a
combined test runner framework and
assertion tool
it isn't the only tool available to
write tests in javascript but arguably
it's you know the standards were kind of
set with libraries like mocker and
jasmine in the early 2010s
and there are other libraries that
enable different categories of testing
you know things are quite popular like
storybook um in the component and ui
testing space
but and newer tools like vitest kind of
a spin-off from veet are up and coming
at the moment but you know as with most
things in software
brand recognition sadly um and support
tends to win
and you know jess has authored them
supported by facebook meta facebook meta
who knows and uh and broadly is the most
well supported across the the tool chain
in the ecosystem so it's probably the
test framework you're going to see the
most
so i want to describe jest and x unit
frameworks in general
so x unit if you didn't know is the not
whilst is the name of a framework in c
sharp it's also the name of the loose
family of frameworks that all implement
roughly the same pattern of test
fixtures and test cases regardless of
the language of choice you're working in
so you know the dominant testing
framework um is tends to be x unit
styled so in javascript there's things
like jest n unit an x unit in c sharp j
unit and java et cetera actually some
trivia the very first x unit
framework was s unit in small talk so
that's kind of where this pattern comes
from and so just as stated is maintained
and supported by facebook and used to
test react you know runs under node
and contains all the stuff you need to
get started
and you know once we have a test
framework we need our assertions and
assertions are used to verify the output
of your functions
now most assertion libraries are just
syntactic sugar over the top of some
conditional checks and throwing
exceptions you can write your own
assertion library in a couple of hours
it's not too difficult and you can bring
your own but you know the truth is with
the testing landscape most tools in 2022
are just fine
like there's a nice thing that we've got
to this place of maturity that
everything is kind of just fine and
you're not going to end up with sucky
tools here they all have individual
wrinkles but they'll work
so people seem to think that the state
of testing in the wild looks like lists
you know you see this diagram in like a
thousand books or a thousand web pages
you've probably not seen like this one
though because unit tests are really
just one of an increasingly broad
category of tests you know we have unit
tests integration tests acceptance tests
end-to-end tests smoke tests
consumer-driven contracts toxicity tests
that's one that most people haven't
heard of ui automation tests mutation
tests
and and you know you know what about bdd
how about gherkin full stack tests
right but different kinds of tests are
designed to help you at different times
during different phases of your
development life cycle so it's kind of
important to know what you're meant to
be doing
so
you know if we look at something at
build time we have problems like code
breaks we have basic integration between
components and like other
nasty code junk
says a ruder word in my slide notes
you know the solutions here we have we
have unit tests and we have coverage so
coverage isn't correctness we have
integration so cross-unit
cross-component tests and you know the
commonalities of all these categories of
tests
is that all of your dependencies are you
can be mocked and stubbed and it's all
in process so there's a category of
tests that's all in process and a build
time
now at deploy time we have different
categories of problems
so you know they're often environmental
they're often consistency based related
to downstream systems they're often
slower to diagnose and debug so you know
the solutions to that is you end up with
different categories of tests like
end-to-end acceptance testing without
mocks
smoke tests that can run against any
environment that are safe and give you a
heads up on on failure right so you
reach for different tools
and then finally at kind of a systems
integration time
you know we have
things like continuous tests running
against third-party systems
consumer-driven contracts to check the
apis you call haven't changed their
shape
and toxicity tests where you write
repeated tests that enforce things like
your standards and check that quality
gates are being met across your software
and you know and the commonality between
all this stuff is all helps you fail
faster that's the point
so while that's a wonderful and diverse
list
of tests that helps you at various
points we need to be careful to crawl
before we run and you know that's enough
theory let's kind of get practical and
you know i remember
i was speaking to a guy called james
gregory years ago and he and he said
something to me that always stuck with
me which was you know what i've used all
these different kinds of tests and the
only thing i reliably care about is
tests that don't break when i don't want
them to
and i thought that was actually quite
revealingly insightful
so it's probably worth highlighting that
while i'd love to be brave and just do
this live in front of you here i do not
have the the nerve to trust both npm and
conference wi-fi at the same time i feel
like that's two gambles that you
shouldn't take at once
so many people will interact with code
bases from some point after they were
first created right and because of that
it's entirely possible that when you're
trying to test in javascript especially
actually you're approaching a project
that's already got like a whole
cavalcade of tooling and gum from npm
strewn all over it and everything is set
up and you kind of don't really know how
this hangs together
so it's no secret the javascript
ecosystem is wide and complex and it's
easy to think that you need a whole
bunch of tooling like webpack and
compilers and god knows what to get
started but really actually you don't
and what we're going to do here is we're
going to new up a new node project
and we're going to install three
packages and i'm going to explain what
those packages do and how you can turn
testing on
so like with everything there are a few
wrinkles you need to navigate in the
form of a tiny bit of configuration but
i'll try and explain not just what the
configuration is but why you need it
now presuming we already have a modern
version of node installed we're going to
just node in a new application here and
install three packages now those
packages are just
just cli and the wonderfully uh catchily
named babel preset m
cool so jest is obviously the test
framework we've been talking about and
we're going to include that in our code
base
in other ecosystems you'll see junit en
unit whatever
just cli is the test runner that can be
called from the command line and it
executes your test code now babel preset
m is a plug-in for babel which is
implicitly used by jest
which what it does is it target it
it compiles your test for whatever
version of node
you have installed automatically when
just runs so you don't need to worry
about webpack and transpilation and
targeting whatever version of yes
current whatever version of node you
support it'll take care of it
so we need to use um
the preset m package to use modern
javascript modules in in our code
along with other language features
so once we've done this npm init we need
to tweak a few things in in package.json
so
we want to first enable es6 modules so
we're going to flip the type of our
project to be a module now you really
everyone should be doing this today and
like set webpack on fire really set
where pack on fire is it's it's a
hellscape that lets you shoot yourself
in the foot with two guns
um please i beg of you so
everyone should use these modules they
work in your browser natively now as
well so there's really no excuse
um so by setting the type property in
your package.json the node runtime
allows you to use the import and export
module syntax
there are other ways you can achieve the
same effect so you can like rename all
your javascript files.mjs
which is just annoying and nobody wants
to do that
so flagging as a module is the cleanest
way once we've done that
we're going to update our scripts
configuration to call jest now
this just means that when we type npm
run test on our command line it will
actually do something now you can
install jest as a global tool and make
sure it's in your path and all sorts of
stuff
but i don't know why you would do that i
don't know why it supports that at all
and and then finally we're going to add
some babel configuration the most arcane
looking bit of all this
um so this configuration
uh can appear arcane but it's better
than trying to learn how to use webpack
and uh if if you get this right you
should never have to look at it ever
again
all we're saying here is configure
jest's implicitly called version of
babel to apply the preset for our
current version of node
and a lot of brackets
so it's probably worth noting if you're
using typescript you'll probably end up
using something like ts jest instead and
you won't need to do this because it
already has
compilers that make sure the packaging
and module system work so you don't need
to worry about it so much
now let's take a look at a very very
basic jest test now i don't know if
anyone's seen this before
um first note that we've we've called it
index.spec.js.js
jason um
so just by default looks for things
called.spec now i know certainly you
know if you're from like a.net
background that's a weird naming
convention because spec
has other connotations in in their
ecosystem but um you know you can
configure it to use like
star.test.js if you want to but that
involves extra config that you don't
really need
so we're going to go through a few
things
we have a file that exports a single
function here on the right
and now on the left there's a test file
illustrating just standard testing
conventions so there's an import for our
code a describe block with an embedded
closure for the tests and an it block
with the test inside of it
now the it block is our is our test
method um the name of the test lives in
the brackets
and our names follow a very very simple
naming convention of like what happened
under what condition and your expected
output now you can be clever and craft
sentences in jest because it renders the
output funnily
but i rather have tests that i can read
when i'm glancing at the code than
glancing at the test output
now it's worth noting again that we're
using the native import and export
keywords of the language here that's
what we get from es6 modules it works
pretty well
especially if you've perhaps been
trapped in the hell of compatibility
with common js and amd modules in the
past like this is the module system you
expected your language to have
now
if you've not done much javascript in a
long time i'm happy to report that
classes work now too
and uh and you can use them exactly the
same way that you would in other
languages and you might hear a thousand
people blog about how javascript doesn't
understand classes and it's not the
prototype chain stuff bores they're
wrong
you should absolutely use the syntactic
sugar put in the language to help you
organize code in whatever way makes it
more legible to you always they work
fine use them as appropriate
and it works
no animations cool didn't know that was
that
uh
you too can now do tdd and javascript
without any weird tooling that's it
that's like the whole bit at the start
now
this is about as close to using an x
unit framework as in any roughly
comparable language you get and if you
like you can configure an npm watch task
to run your tests repeatedly when you
save your files
but we can probably do better than that
iceberg
now if that's unit testing
what's tdd and why is it different
now obviously test driven development is
a software development process that
relies on the repetition of a short
development cycle now requirements are
turned into specific test cases and then
the software is improved to pass the new
tests only now this is opposed to like
classical software development that
allows software to be added that's not
proven to meet requirements right and
you know this is the the tdd by example
this is the bible it was published in
by this this lovely man this is this is
kemp beck kent becker's are like one
good old white guy
right like kent beck in his own words is
not a great programmer he's just a good
programmer with good habits and i was
that was a really really great sentiment
um so tdd was part of the broader xp the
extreme programming movement of the late
90s and test first was promoted as a
concept from xp since around 1999 or so
and um you know kent beck always just
says he rediscovered this thing
now in beck's own words
the original description of tdd was an
ancient book about programming it said
you take the input tape manually type in
the output tape you expect then program
until the actual output tape matches the
expected output
after i'd written the first x unit
framework in small talk i remembered
reading this and tried it out
and that was the origin of tdd for me
so when describing tdd to all the
programmers i often hear of course how
else could you program
therefore
i uh i refer to my role as rediscovering
tdd
um
everyone remembers the dress right
it's gold and white
well while unit tests are all about
testing the units of code they're not a
workflow right they're not a process or
methodology they're just a programming
tool
and unit test verifying the correctness
of your implementation is their entire
job that's it right so test driven
development conversely is all about
building out new pieces of functionality
of behavior and verifying that instead
now tdd is a working practice an
approach with the tests you produce
existing almost as a side effect
now it's why advocates of the process
describe it as test-driven design
sometimes
where really what you're doing is
discovering the structure of your
program through experimentation and
testing
so advocates for this approach including
myself believe this reduces waste and
over design because we've all seen some
stuff
now
the tdd method is described as red green
refactor
and in the red phase your challenge is
to get a test failing as quickly as
possible
now that red can be as simple as
non-valid code or non-compiling code in
compiled languages
and this red test expresses an outcome a
thing that you wish your software did
now then the challenge is to do the
simplest thing that can possibly work to
make the tesco green and so help me god
so many people struggle with the concept
of the simplest thing that can possibly
work and you know it might be pasting in
some dubious code from stack overflow
that's cool i see you i'm okay with that
you know it might be hacking some ugly
code that just gets the job done
or even hard coding a value that's my
favorite
now the people that get tdd wrong
stop here
right
they get green and they stop and they
ship it
the final part is the iterative loop
it's refactoring the code to make it
good enough
it's the most important part of tdd and
of the workflow because it's where you
shift things around literally changing
the factoring
but not the behavior supported by your
hopefully still green test
now again in tdd by example
what it says is that different phases
can have different purposes
they call for different styles of
solution different aesthetic viewpoints
and um the first three phases need to go
by quickly so we get to a known state
where the new with the new functionality
we can commit any number of sins to get
there we all love sins
um
because speed trumps design just for
that brief moment
so to the developer of software the
argument for any kind of code based
testing is very very simple
is it faster than running the program
and it always is
so after that brief kind of history
lesson and my subtle adoring of mr beck
um
we're gonna get back to the the
practical stuff so the thing about those
tdd workflows
they mean you end up running your code
like a lot a lot a lot a lot a lot a lot
like so frequently you bash out the keys
for the the running test runners and in
javascript the standard solution for
this is to use a file watcher and you
know run your tests every time the files
get saved but there is a better way
continuous test runs execute any tests
affected by changes you make to your
software on each and every key press
instantly inside of your editor
now the first time i used a continuous
test runner i didn't really understand
what all the fuss was about and this was
encryption.net and i was pairing with
someone for two days and at the end of
the first day i went and bought my own
copy because it literally changed my
programming workflow so significantly
i've never looked back
so wallaby is a continuous test runner
for javascript and for the rest of the
session when you see screenshots from vs
code we'll be using wallaby now it's
it's amazing it's by far and away the
best tool in all of javascript and
perhaps the best continuous test runner
i've ever used it's not free it costs
you 99 pounds a year i think
199 pounds for organizations it's worth
every single penny you will like make
that money back instantly and i'm going
to resist the urge i'm not going to
resist the urge to climb on myself my
soapbox and labor the point there's
professionals we should be buying
software from other professionals or we
all go hungry
so please please support tiny companies
with good tools
um they're not essential to do tdd
continuous test runners but like
honestly i'll make your orders of
magnitude faster and they really don't
pay me for this
so running with wallaby you no longer
have to use any npm watchers
there's a whole host of other features
you can do things like log in line
and watch the results output inside your
ide
you can get instant feedback on code
changes and you can do wild stuff like
debugging backwards through your code
so you can step backwards and see the
entire stack it's really wild and very
very good
um wallaby's amazing they should
probably pay me for this promo
so you can see here if i change my
invoke function to return false wallaby
provides this in ide feedback so you get
the kind of stuff you would see on the
console right in line
buy it or nag your boss
both
okay so now we understand what a test is
we understand what jest is we understand
what a test runner is and assertions are
um i want to talk a little bit about
something i really love and
i've been thinking about this for about
15 years
it's about intentionality in code
so i suppose what we have to do is we
have to address the elephant in the room
ready to be mad everyone ready to be mad
oh this guy
burn your cop is a clean code it's aged
very poorly and it means we do not have
to [__] with he who shall not be named
um it's not classy to twist the knife
but suffers to say everything in beck's
work dwarfs everyone's least favorite
family member
clean code is an extremely dogmatic book
and its presence in the industry has
reduced discussions about quality to the
discussions about naming variables
its muted conversations about
architectural style in the same way
dogmatic adherence to the solid
principles has stopped intelligent
conversations about architecture
its shadow is long
and it's one of thoughtless dogma
followed blindly
please don't
heresy i hear you cry you can't say that
about clean code i love writing clean
code
so
there was a point in my career why where
i too thought the rules around basic
hygiene were enough
um but over the last five or so years
i've come to value intentionality in
code
over any sense of syntactic cleanliness
so what does that mean
it means that every character matters
every single thing you do now the most
valuable thing i learned about software
was to reason about it like a body of
literature
it has text it has subtext it has
authorial intent
software is the means of communicating
intent between developer and developer
sometimes we get it more right than
others but in writing our code and
especially in writing our tests i want
you to approach the work as if every
character matters
be intentional the white space matters
the rhythm of your code matters naming
does matter
form matters function matters
and when we're talking about writing
tests that survive that are legible that
are useful
tests written with thoughtfulness and
intentionality for the reader of what
matters
so let's start with a few guiding
principles iceberg
and then we can get really really deep
into specific examples
now good tests test the what not the how
they're not implementation specific they
don't require huge amounts of state to
understand they test single things be
they concepts outputs or functions
and they need to be just as good
just as intentional as the code that you
are testing
now i'm going to go through some
examples of how we can make some tests
look good from both bad and good
perspectives so this is like
the first tier of knowing things about
tests now
the aaa pattern i like it because it
sounds like screaming
so tests should as a general rule follow
this arrange act assert patterns like
stanzas in a poem
they should make it easier to understand
the intent of the code because it splits
up the preparation of test data the
actual test and then the assertions now
you'll hopefully see this pattern
everywhere if you've ever written any
tests before
even if you didn't know it had a name
um also while tempting to call out what
you're doing please use whitespace
intentionally to so please don't add
slash slash arrange slash slash act
slash
like we all we know what it means
please don't it's an organizational
pattern it doesn't have to make your
code ugly
so where possible we should use
relatively standard names for things
like system under test
and the names of the tests themselves
you know as a general rule people have
trended towards using sut standing for
system under test to describe the thing
that you're testing where possible
this is the most relevant in situations
where you're testing classes or entire
composed applications or modules where
you have dependencies flying around now
it makes it more obvious when you're
interacting with your test code and when
you're interacting with the unit of
isolation
we're also using a standard naming
pattern for tests that i mentioned
before kind of formatting aside the test
name should always tell you what you're
invoking under what condition and what
expectation you have of the thing
the number of codebases i've seen with
test one test two test three like people
think it's not out there but it's
everywhere
so
here's an example file so i horrifyingly
um
went shopping for big javascript
projects with tests and it took me a
while to find them um so i borrowed this
spec file from an mit licensed major
open source project on the internet
um we're not going to name and shame
it's from some test code regarding the
handling of site configuration
and it's certainly not the worst test
file i've ever seen but what we're going
to do we're going to go through a number
of techniques that would improve its
quality and maintain ability and
readability and you know everything
matters even things this small so we're
going to revisit this a few times but
that's what it started off like
and yeah i'm not really sure what it
does
so firstly use white space wisely
you know in this example one of the
handful of problems is that a total lack
of white space in the test file here
slows down your comprehension
now white space exists in code the same
reason it exists in written language
to help direct the reader to give you a
pause to let you think use it
the file on the left here has absolutely
no significant white space indicating
either the different tests or that
there's clearly different phases in
these individual test functions but
they're totally not delineated
so introducing some new lines are shown
to the right makes the tests easier to
read because you know when you're meant
to pause
so people that fall in that do this fall
into this trap of making their tests
this terse and they do it because they
mistake uniformity the way something
looks neat and similar they mistake that
for expressiveness
where we use form and shape
intentionally to convey meaning
it's far better for distinct parts of
your test files and functions or any
code at all
to look different when they do different
things because the visual variation
leads the eye encourages reading
instead of the skimming that large
bodies of identical looking text leads
to right and i know it's weird kind of
approaching this from a pure aesthetic
viewpoint but it's really it's design
now
no magic numbers
and like most test code bases i ever see
suffer this problem so magic numbers in
test code are even more evil than magic
numbers in real code
because they make me believe that the
value of that thing is important
right so if i see a minus -2 and a test
i think it means something i think
there's something special in that code
that's going to react to that right you
should always give test input data names
to establish context
right because here the -1
is a magic number and needs a name now i
need the author of the test to tell me
why that it is that number
i need to know if i should worry about
it or not
even though i'm describing this as magic
numbers it applies to all test data you
know we've got to make sure there are no
magic strings that appear to have
meaning either or any data structures
that look real
so one of the common tricks to make your
test data stand out is to literally call
it out in the data you know if you're
passing a string to a function that you
don't care about why not give it a value
of
some valid data or unimportant data to
make it really obviously garbage
so the reader understands that it isn't
important
and in this specific example we could
have also relied on the test name to
provide the invalid weak context that we
see here you know it's not quite as
legible
as as the -1 still feels a little bit
magic but in a test so small context is
key and it's a tolerable compromise
it probably doesn't affect the
experience of the reader if we make it
smaller here
and you know again remember golden rule
always optimizing for the reader
now we should also avoid unnecessary
data
like a relevant test code that doesn't
affect the execution of the software
should not be in your tests ever
so here the unnecessary test data all of
those those headers make you think that
they're important they make you think
that's what a valid request looks like
but if you actually look at the code
it's not true right it's impossible to
understand what's going on in this test
because you just suck a punch by a wall
of text and noise and chaos
that's the name of my grindcore album
you need to make sure that
when you're specifying test data you
include only the data that impacts the
behavior of the test themselves because
anything else is a distraction and pulls
the reader into thinking that's required
so remove the noise to increase the
legibility
now
now you can see the exact condition that
triggers the behavior testing for
because our actual implementation
only actually checks the request method
property
and we can slim down the test code to
only specify the data that triggers our
check you know in this case it has to be
a get or it throws
now as much as possible we should avoid
repetition in test data too because the
visual noise causes the reader to start
skimming and not recognize the
difference between those tests
so here we have code that requires a
whole lot of test data to execute but
because we're testing two different
scenarios we have two different tests
you know we need to extract the
commonalities between those two tests
now by extracting out the request
construction
we can more clearly see the intent of
our code
rather than be blindsided by the noise
of test data everywhere
our valid request with function takes
two arguments that will create test data
in the correct correct form for both of
those tests and yes before anybody yells
we are technically drying out our tesco
base here i know
um but you should always strive to
remove any statements that are
inconsequential from the understanding
of the test to something else elsewhere
like tests should be tiny
now
this looks like the same slide but it
isn't
it's important to keep your tests up to
date with the latest language changes
available to you too you know this might
seem as though it's the same but we can
use more modern javascript language
features to improve visual noise
so here what we're doing that's
different is we're destructuring the
results of the http get function and
extracting the body
and using includes instead of like index
of and the relatively arcane minus one
there to check if our return string
contains a data value or the other data
value now these subtle improvements to
language may seem invisible at skim read
but when you're the developer trying to
read the work and understand why
something is broken
tight legible production grade test code
will make your life a tremendous amount
easier
you should continually revisit and
update your test code as your software
grows
and as languages tooling and standards
change around you too and you're going
to remember like like all software it is
never done you've never written the
tests and they're finished things change
now
if you find yourself extracting similar
categories of data
to helper functions too often your code
base might be in need of some kind of
test data building pattern so this is
another common approach so test data
builder functions or classes
functions or classes for well-known
categories of test data remove visual
noise not only from the test but to a
completely different location altogether
to make it easier to comprehend
now
they they do this and you can use your
test data builders to construct known
categories of test data that can then be
shared amongst different tests um think
of it as like ddd but for tests i guess
is probably the easiest way to think
about it you know you make your test
cases a first class concept in your
application so again it makes it much
easier for future developers to
understand what you were thinking
and
you know it's trivial
to accidentally add dependencies on how
to process systems that you don't
control
so it's important that we also isolate
our tests from
data storage or anything you request
over the network
now if you're caught online or get rate
limited here your tests become reliable
and flicker
now we're inevitably going to talk about
you know mocking here and mocking is
dangerous
so you can't you can use jest's built-in
mock functions to mock the behavior of
other modules or files in your
applications but if you go and like
google just documentation for this stuff
it like it's really bad really really
exceptionally poor
like this is the easiest way to do it
now just has this whole convention where
you can add like
files with pre-canned mocks in them but
i don't know why you would ever use any
of that stuff because all you're doing
is you're taking logic that behave
belongs in your test and just putting it
in a random directory somewhere else
like it doesn't make any sense it's a
really silly approach
so it's important to highlight that in
javascript you have to make sure that
you call just mock
before you import anything else from the
module you want to mock otherwise the
package loader will grab your actual
code rather than the uh the mock
so at the very top of the file we're
mocking out node fetch here this
prevents any imports accidentally like
loading our real dependency
and then you should be careful when
introducing mocks into your test code
because mocking again is the act of
swapping out one dependency for another
but it's very common the tests that use
extensive amounts of mocking become
brittle
now as any change in the way one
component uses another often induces
rippling changes throughout the code
base all of those tests with deep mocks
around expectations will all break
so use mocks but try and use them to
only isolate yourself from external
systems that you can't control
like web apis or databases or sometimes
the file system
if you're mocking out your own code
often what you're really doing is you're
building software that's tying you into
a specific implementation
so
you should assert on only one concept
or capability per test now this is often
misinterpreted as meaning only one
assert statement right like a classic
fumble of words um but we can be far
gentler here and you know in this
example
we're testing that a library can reset
its configuration now it clearly
contains two kinds of configuration some
kind of global site config and some
regular config object
now the ability to reset both of these
values are individual features of the
code and should be split into two
separate tests even though the resulting
output looks worse
it looks like weird copy and pasted
stuff but we'll come back and we'll tidy
it up a bit later
now
what i want to do is i want to revisit
this this example file and see if we can
apply some of the techniques here now
before we did anything to the file it
looked like this this is the whole file
split left to right now yeah i'm not
really sure what
properly means um
i don't know what a directive is
and like god knows what all those
different conflict files are
exactly the same set of assertions
could be written like that by following
those rules
you know some gentle rework we reduce it
down to this so what did we actually do
here
now we reduce the cognitive load so that
every single thing you see in those test
lines matters
we introduce white space to help the
reader split out some concepts into
their own tests
but most importantly in you know the one
most significant change is that we stop
testing the basic the basics again and
again and again in every test
all of those tests here just repeat the
same assertions
stupid it doesn't make any sense
you know they're relying on distinct
what we're doing now is you know relying
on distinct tests to cover scenarios
um because that that copy paste and
previous test was obscuring the actual
intent of the individual tests now i
know it doesn't seem like much but i
hope you'll agree the difference here to
legibility is like pretty huge actually
and you know of the tests you know
especially with some rework naming it's
really significant because again
intentionality every line of code
matters there and i cannot say the same
thing about all that
so okay next level there
so far we've spoken about the small
minutiae of increasing legibility of our
tests but i want to talk to you about my
two big rules like these are the most
important things in all the testing
you test what not how
and you test the capabilities of code
not the data in your tests
now i believe that these two things
together are the difference between
poorly factored tests and tests that
last
let's look at what that really means
so testing the exact implementation of a
dependency is one of the most common
pitfalls in testing
you should be testing the outcomes of
your system under test
not how they reach their conclusion
now tests that test precise
implementations are brittle to change
and you'll have to rework them if you
ever change the code
so
test that um
sorry
test the test the outcomes of a piece of
code are resilient to change and can
have implementation swapped over time
while the tests still remain valid and
that's like one of these big golden
rules it's a gold standard to check if
you've got a good test can i replace my
entire implementation and have my test
still work
now in this example we're asserting
explicitly that our weather api is
called by url and that's a leaky
abstraction because there's an api key
in there like this is literally testing
how we are reaching our conclusion not
the outcomes of the test
and you know as soon as our api key
changes the tests blow up and we didn't
break our code our code still works
it's leaking knowledge also of the
document response formats of the
underlying system
now if we change our weather api this
test will still pass
here when we're testing the what perhaps
with a single change to our weather api
returns temp helper function
so it's important to note that we're
still exposing some elements of the
implementation here you know our test
code still needs to know what the format
the response body from that weather api
is
but it's the smallest possible
compromise we can make to make this a
good test you know it's okay if you have
to change one of your testing
abstractions
if your implementation significantly
changes like it's okay it's not the end
of the world but you want to make sure
the blast radius of those changes are
very very small so by building these
kind of helper methods to construct this
stuff we keep those changes centralized
now you could go further and you could
extract this logic into its own specific
adapter class but for a scenario this
narrow what you'd end up doing is
writing tests around the adapter then
test that you checking that you were
calling the adapter and then a simple
refactor
would
mean you'd have to change two things
that are really asserting the same
concept it doesn't really make any sense
but and also don't hardcode api keys
stupid
okay so the best example of testing
capabilities over data is the diamond
cutter
the funny thing is i use this as an
interview question
so i hope no one's watching
the diamond catter if you've never heard
of it is probably my favorite tdd
exercise
the idea is simple
given a character from the alphabet
print a diamond of its output with the
character being on the middle line of
the diamond
you can see the desired output in the
the slide here but the idea is that you
incrementally build up each of the
features
of the code that generates the diamond
bit by bit it's a tdd cutter
and it's especially tricky as a tdd
cutter because well the alphabet's
really well known people know the data
so they fall into a trap
now it isn't too difficult there are
probably like 20 ways of solving this
that i've seen that i can trivially
remember
here is a solution i'm using for this
cutter don't worry too much about how it
works um it's it's the testing style
that we really care about but in this
case in case you're curious the solution
we're using is to loop all the way up
the alphabet to generate the top half of
the diamond we're doing a second loop to
pad out the bit in the middle and then
we're flipping and mirroring it right
now
this is the example of the kind of tests
i often see for the diamond cutter
these ocean boiling tests that you know
they're not just testing the data but
they're also
very hard to incrementally incrementally
tdd because they require this entire
fully working thing to pass
like if you write tests like this it
stops you from decomposing the problem
that you're working on into these
smaller chunks
and and because it'll take almost the
entire time you're programming to get a
green test you kind of break that red
green refactor workflow right yeah it's
kind of red
finish it
right you know it's a perfect example of
how people often start trying to think
about the diamond cutter and it's why
it's my favorite testing example because
it's basically this isn't it
right don't write tests like that like
tests like this make the draw the rest
of the owl
thing real in your implementation
like we don't want to do this
so a better solution
focuses on the capabilities of your code
and not the data
now you'll notice we go out of our way
here to turn the data into categories or
classes of data
so you see we have an edge case we have
a and then another category which is all
of the letters that aren't a
but you could pretty much change the
test data in these tests and they would
all still work right so we're building
up a test by inspecting the qualities of
the code that constructs a diamond for
the output and we're testing what the
code does rather than just that it does
it at all
so this means that if any of our
specific capabilities get broken like
the padding or making sure the diamond's
the right length
we'll know which bit of the code failed
not just it's broken
um so learning to test what and not the
how is in my opinion the most important
lesson you will ever learn in testing
like this is what makes good tests
now there's actually an argument here
that given the problem posed by the
diamond cutter you could just hard code
26 diamonds and it'd be fine and you
know what i would accept that as a
solution because a constrained problem
space but like fugly
okay so
final tier
we arrived at this weird inflection
point where we have so many different
types of tests that actually it makes
things more confusing not less
it's funny that
so people get stuck in these like
cyclical conversations about what type
of test to use in what context
and because there are just so many
definitions going around and just so
many subtle misalignments around the
different types of testing
that perhaps we need a bit of a radical
simplification to all this stuff now
and you know
i'm going to blame something i think
it's all because of integration tests
so
i want to talk about the murder of
integration tests and their replacement
with a thing that we barely have a name
for yet because there's no better way to
come to a standard by making up a new
name
so integration tests are dead the
history they're useless totally useless
artifacts from a simpler time they're a
complete contradiction
see if i were to ask a handful of people
in this room
i could probably source a handful of
different definitions of what an
integration test is
um there's the traditional definition
where an integration test is a test
covering the interactions between more
than one classal function that's it now
there are folks that use them to
describe tests that include
the integration of your code and
external systems like databases that are
within your control
and then there's a piece people that use
them to describe testing everything
except the integration of your code with
external systems like databases so the
two opposite definitions
and i'm faced with this fundamental
contradiction but probably best just
setting fire to the term and never using
it again like it's garbage it doesn't
mean anything it's too broad sorry
integration tests we loved you but
you're dead
it's the literally a programming where
recently literally was redefined to also
include figuratively as one of its
possible definitions
dumb
so
at the same time as integration tests
having lost their identity
the sentiment of integration tests is
more powerful than ever more popular
than ever
now as our computers have increased in
power and our test frameworks have
become more sophisticated
the kind of fast feedback cycles
previously reserved for the humble unit
test have been expanded to a place where
you're using modern tooling and you know
you're capable of running your entire
application in memory instantly
even more interestingly when you combine
the speed at which we can now run our
entire apps in memory with the more
sophisticated approaches to kind of
mocking and stubbing it's increasingly
common
to find test suites that can be mostly
executed outside in
but with tiny invasive cuts to switch
out data storage or network services
and network dependencies with something
that can be manipulated from within the
test code base now
these full stack tests or in memory
tests or
integration tests
by some definition and they allow you
the liberty to tdd
the what you want your application your
website your api to do without really
having to worry so much about like
traditional
low-level integration tests and over the
past five or so years everything has
kind of sped up
and services have become smaller because
of microservices it's an increasingly
popular style of testing
but it's kind of like
it's the testing style that's a little
bit of all those other testing styles
um so why is it been so difficult to
find a name that sticks right you know
and it's more about workflow and test
isolation than what you're testing
actually and it's related to the
increase in performance of tools over
time but you know it's it's okay i'd
rather we not like lose ourself trying
to catch uh to coin a catchy name
and spend the time actually thinking
about the thing right and i think the
one real defining characteristic of this
style of testing
is its tests and as much of your
application as possible in process
that's that's what it is
and um and in process matters because
when it's all in process you can
interact with the stubs and you can
really you can play around with the
small incisions it's really really good
so if we're struggling to find a name
for this style um what are its
characteristics
now
tests are fast and execute in memory
like unit tests they don't you know the
order doesn't matter
the test shouldn't affect each other
they're not brittle so you can change
all of your implementation in the middle
and the test should still pass
they test high level business
functionality and then some low level
detail where required
and they're generally authored in this
high level to low level tdd-ish workflow
right and they should still pass if you
provide them with a different test test
data of the same category or class
now
just because none of the names feel
quite right does not mean people have
not tried to name this thing
um obviously some people seem to have
settled on component testing
um but it feels a little overloaded to
me because you know it's easy to mistake
it for things like web components or
some other kind of components i feel
like component is one of the most
overused words in our entire lexicon
um that
you know maybe what it really is is just
the tests for our program
so perhaps you know instead we should
follow ian cooper's lead i don't know if
you've seen ian's tdd where all went
wrong talk where he describes the
emerging style simply as developer tests
and i kind of like that it is after all
what they are
um we don't need to lose ourselves
trying to articulate the subtle
differences
between subtle different variants of
these things than to be useful to us
now the most important thing to me about
this style of testing is that it goes
hand in hand with the tdd-style workflow
if slightly adjusted
now while writing traditional tests it
was common to start writing a test for a
class
and then you get some kind of system
boundary and you would introduce a mock
object and write tests that verified the
behavior of that mock
and then you peel the onion back and you
go down a level and you repeat that
process until you reach the very very
bottom of the stack now
it's a fairly slow and laborious process
and has often led to a huge amount of
repetition
in both test scenarios and the kinds of
tests that were left behind you know by
this movement of tests being mostly in
memory we can change this process to be
better
now instead of peeling layers off our
software away one by one
we can focus on a test driven almost
behavior driven style of testing
around the outside of our functionality
at a speed previously only available to
unit tests so you know what this means
instead of this repeated cycle of red
green refactor at every level of our
code as we start outside in
and then as soon as we usually consider
reaching for a mock
actually and you know testing
abstraction we should instead break out
into a very very low level unit test
around the piece of functionality that
we're struggling with
we we make those test paths around the
little pocket of complexity and then
instead of like using a di container or
injecting it just new it up and use it
right and then
then the top level test goes green
and then you continue so you end up with
detailed tests around the complex bits
of your software and tests around your
expectations of what it does
you know it's it's beautiful there's no
need to needlessly build layered
software
we just call the code
it's cool and it's a style much more
compatible with modern microservices and
feature-based organization than like
dogmatic onion-layered end-tiered
architectures
now
this repeated cycle of high-level to
low-level testing results in code bases
with less compromises made for testing
ironically
and with architectures that are more
amenable to change because the tests are
all either very high level what does
this do
or a very detail-oriented level here is
a pocket of complexity that we need to
understand
we're liberated from the repetitive
onion peel test code bases that are like
treacle
and that the damage our code's ability
to change
and you know
what we're really doing is building code
that's able to change easily and that's
the most important metric really that's
that's the real deal
now
in the mid 2000s when lots of thinking
and writing on this topic happened the
london extreme tuesday club popularized
the idea of what later became known as
moccas testing
that's the same onion peel approach
where each layer of software
mocks and tests its expectations of the
one below it now
it was promoted as an alternative to a
traditional classical tdd
and i think this new wave of developer
tests
both replaces that style completely
and illuminates the negative side
effects it's had on all of software
um the london school moccase style
testing is brittle and doesn't survive
and doesn't last and was a mistake
so how do you make tests that don't suck
don't do that
thank you
any questions
go set fire to clean code